trente ans d'accompagnement c'est ce que
fait cette année l'antenne locale les
petits frères des pauvres à l'occasion
des niveaux les personnes âgées se sont
réunis pour célébrer et donner un coup
d'oeil dans le rétroviseur de toutes ces
années au service de nos aînés en
situation d'isolement à l'époque comme
je vous disais tout à l'heure à l'époque
on a plein de réseaux sociaux et bien il
faut des associations comme ça il faut
mettre de l'humain faut aller voir les
gens discutent avec eux essayer de
régler leurs problèmes il ya plus en
plus de gens qui sont seuls depuis sa
création l'association vise à soutenir
les personnes âgées à domicile ou en
institution en organisant des visites
des rencontres des sorties ou encore des
mini séjours l'émission ses doigts c'est
principalement de se rendre à domicile
chez les personnages et donc qui habite
sol afin de leur de leur donner un petit
peu de bon temps de discuter avec elle
et en plus de ça donc il ya des actions
collectives et deux bénévoles en
permanence ils viennent me voir chaque
semaine
ensuite les activités au local on à
evans évidemment les anniversaires avec
petits gâteaux et cadeaux en france une
personne âgée sur quatre souffrent
d'isolement parmi celles-ci 300 ils sont
en état de mort sociale avec le
confinement qui a fragilisé les liens
l'association est plus que jamais
nécessaire je pense que bon la crise
sanitaire a
à fragiliser le
les personnes âgées elles sont encore
plus isolée qu'avant et il y en a
beaucoup qui ont du mal à refaire
surface à à revoir du monde à ressortir
à se socialiser parce que ça nous permet
de rire et puis de voir le luron plat le
vous ai dis pas la solitude mais l'ennui
comme chaque année une fête de noël est
prévu avec un repas des animations et
une distribution de cadeaux le 23
décembre prochain